[Laughter]
I'm literally just texting my mom she's
so excited to be on yeah chronic I've
never been mortified in my life as my
friend your friend we're all right let
me put our D and D do not disturb agony
and you're the boob like hi guys
hi guys today i'm here with the farro my
housemates her housemate yeah
how has made fun video what we doing
today playing for tonight
and some of you who know me are probably
like why are you playing fortnight and
if you don't know me i am really bad at
shooter games and i never play online
game I'm worse than her a shooter games
I don't play any games so this is gonna
be fun and confusing we have I've never
actually even seen for tonight I've seen
like means of it but I don't really know
what to expect so I just said so far
like should we play all night and then
we are playing like what layout I'll
play a versus engine I'm guessing we're
gonna be playing the people's weather so
let's play the people
in the Battle Royale but we're gonna
lose yeah of course that's my whole
point of this video the world will never
be the same brace for impact
[Music]
[Music]
how do you enter oh my god howdy John
John's here before me how do you how do
you get in this
I don't know I'm I'm pressing buttons
and there's no welcome to buy a house
and I are they meeting you party finder
[Laughter]
where is the party finer okay say when
you're yes man if you look at the plus
next to your player come back yeah and
then it gives you a list of people that
were online and you press the X button
to environment like far is on my
playstation and she's just in it's like
my guest
oh I don't know whether or not that is
possible let me let me just have a quick
look can I know they're saying it's not
split screen room can't be that social
yeah your muffin says share the
controller we were will share it like
Akashi do this funny okay so I'm looking
up and down
and I've got my triggers oh yeah
if you press the don't know what the
buttons are all of the big like let's
just line to the back of here in great
thousand trees and then you'll be able
to learn rainbow trail okay where are
you taking it in turns like one person
holding one bit the controller the other
amazing nobody gets left so if you if
you've got your axe you want to pick up
one of these trees just hit it bunch
when you see the circle if you hit that
circle it does more damage to the tree
and makes it quicker
I hid this not the circle in your
control of the circle when you're
hitting the tree but now that you've
brought that you can do you can do
little edits to it so whilst you're
looking at it with the B button press
the right trigger to take out little
circles of it and you can do tiny little
edits I'm just gonna break down some
trees so I can demonstrate so when when
you press this the circle button yes if
I gave you that jump up with the X
button yeah now there's different things
that you can do to that edit as well so
if you to get rid of four of them yet
archway it is basically minecraft with
guns
I don't know there's some creepy people
on this game but real people yeah let me
worry so if you look at me so there's on
the floor is an assault rifle and a
shotgun they've got their different
ranges the purple thing in your radar is
the storm which does damage over time
for as long as you're in it suit just
don't want to let that touch my head
yeah it's quite pretty but it's
[Laughter]
no dancing pounder you can fast as much
as you like then let them tell you sorry
I'm playing around with far as half of
controller dance there down the B+ in
there what does she go for let's see if
we can park all this yeah we can look
there we go we got this yeah nice to lie
yeah okay yeah it's cool I understand my
heart I feel enjoy do I need to how you
guys finding a controller like that
right now I feel like a Siamese twin
yeah
storms coming again so we're gonna move
on a little more
there's only 18 people left I'm coming
back up to you
[Laughter]
[Music]
[Laughter]
[Laughter]
[Laughter]
how's just time hey you guys doing
anyway if you been doing with the rest
of the day I've been packing up to move
back home okay let's just carry on where
do you wanna go
if you press in the middle button then
look the controller or one above the
PlayStation button that shows you a map
[Music]
with the our way but wailing I won I won
and then press the X button to jump out
and then head towards the mark on your
compass you see a little like
turn off turn off in that first okay we
don't want to go down to too much before
we want to go to the wailing woods yeah
use the X button to activate your glider
earlier
that's gonna chop some stuff down let's
go find some guns
so I'm guessing all the guns like around
the town this mainly yeah you can find
them in chests in boxes that kind of
thing I'm just trying to work out with
you okay they you're over this way you
know it's purple that's good okay let's
not tie it down
oh you guys go to yeah so with your
combined shooting ability it should be
quiet you can use a telescope and that's
a really fun way to okay Undead oh it's
them to us refer running stay safe you
don't go that way though cuz you're
going away from this tool you're going
away from this circle you want to go the
other way
oh yeah cuz the circle is closing in
also you only like a cantering at the
moment if you hold the analog stick down
more towards run wait are we in the
storm are we in the Powerball
oh yeah are we gonna die you're gonna
take damage until you get out of it
[Laughter]
little blue lion on the radar is the
quickest route to get out of the store
still okay you ready you ready you ready
you ready you ready if you pick up those
rocks one of those rocks if you use the
square button on it makes your jumpin
bear now now press the X button to jump
left
Medina hello anybody home it forward a
bit I'm gonna change what gun okay back
back a little bit left left left
okay good boy I cannot see where that
person is press r2 so we were like Amy
issuing a tiara is making me laugh so
much watching the attempt to turn around
so I can see how much about
concentrating as you can you can support
on patreon.com slash is it yang man ex
support is greatly welcomed you can
subscribe over here on the YouTube
channel right now you can follow her on
Twitter for updates as to when she's
going to be doing things like this if
you really want to there's some
fantastic moments to come
so if you want to come back here to some
bandages that you can pick up and heal
yourself with we jump no want to make
them okay so we're very close
let's run referre let's run go running
powers in sir action music now if we
just get one one like shot in I'll be
there is someone building on top of one
of the houses over to the west the other
side of this bond
yeah they started fighting no mess of me
watching you guys just running out the
front there's someone else out the back
of this someone on the roof this fight
is yours on the roof
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
amazing
yeah we're saying we're for me to go now
because my broom is getting so hot and
her hand is moist so that was us playing
for tonight thanks for watching I hope
you enjoyed everything that was a lovely
day yeah have a lovely day or evening
wherever time it is have a lovely time
agreed and subscribe okay like the video
we don't know how to play this yes to my
promo for me I'm guilty to do it we
don't know how they'll if you lost like
the video comment down below your
favorite game
[Laughter]
you
[Music]